connecté avec soi un facteur second
souci pour tout changer mais j'ai comme
ça tout changer mais avant d'aller l'on
doit contrer mon histoire à - est à peu
près 12 ans j'avais un problème de santé
et a installé au dakar et j'ai demandé
qu'est ce qui se passe avec moi et ils
m'ont trouvé que je faisais la cnsa mine
sévère
j'ai réitéré ce béret 54 x alors donc
vraiment j'ai pas dormi longtemps et
quand même on prescrit machine pour
respirer la nuit sa rente inspire de
l'oxygène dans dans nos poumons et j'ai
dormi pour la première fois le 8 heures
de ma vie j'ai jamais 2008 ans et quand
je me suis réveillée le matin j'avais un
énergie dans moi que je connaissais pas
cette façon-là d'être allumée et quand
je suis revenu le matin alors je me suis
regardé dans le miroir qui je
connaissais pas ce monsieur nous donne
et qu'est-ce que j'ai aperçu ce que
toutes les pensées négatives que j'avais
à vingt sept rebelles a été plus long
était partie il ya aussi running gag à
la maison à quand mes enfants étaient la
marque avant la machine qui marque après
le machin et j'étais complet en automne
ma façon de penser ma façon de parler
était complètement différent et je me
suis posé quelques soucis mais pourquoi
ça arrive
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ma vie que
ça m'arrive donc à ce moment là j'ai
pris la décision de
faire un jean de kayes d'un jean de
recherche pourquoi pourquoi ça m'arrive
à moi et d'un viven auterive d'un
conférence à nos conférences toutes les
informations que j'eus a pris 5,1 pour
savoir qu'est ce qui se passait avec moi
cinq ans de recherches en arrière à cinq
ans de recherche comment que le cerveau
fonctionne comment on est contrôlé
manipulé par plusieurs facteurs
et j'ai aperçu
selon me rachat ce que j'ai eu c'est
qu'un jeune fille programmée et oui on
nie tout ce programme une certaine façon
on a à peu près 50 à 75 mille pensées
par jour imagine s'est passé l'autre
vous êtes en train de vous dire
incroyable et fait penser là sont basés
sur à l'information que vous avez eu de
vos parents des amis
notre société vous programme cette
insolente tous nos programmes viennent d
extérieur de nos lascars trop haut
qu'est ce que je fais avec sow et dans
qu'est ce que je fais que mon niveau
la façon que je sens en éveil tous qu'on
est dans cette énergie lanvian nous et
sommes en recherche
j'ai trouvé une façon de faire impose de
nous et cette ressource rare et marne et
à trouver un couloir le coup leur camp
mais tu n'as pas de quelle couleur dans
la teinte pour le moment qu'on est dans
cette couleur
tous nos programmes n'arrête à
fonctionner même chose quand j'étais
devant le miroir quand je suis dans ces
lacs certainement même sens
et quand on est dans cette couleur là on
a commencé à voir des choses un peu
différent d'un avis la programmation est
plus loin donc la seule chose qui nous
reste c'est nous nos choix nous et quand
on est dans cette cette énergie lors des
petits cons et parce que la couleur vont
nous permettre de tracer la
programmation et de se connecter et
quand on est connecté on est présent
avec nous on est par ailleurs au niveau
notre programmation
on y parlait on y donne atteinte qu'en
aidant à atteindre
on est plus présent avec nous le trail
pense mais on va prendre ce train là et
je trouve cette façon là de se connecter
et quand les qualités tout devient nous
tous nos choix qu'on fait des devis à
partir de la taxe attaquant vient de moi
et uniquement - donc ce que je choisis
qu'est ce que je veux de ma vie je peux
travailler ou que je veux je peux avoir
lamoureux que je veux dans ma vie je
peux tout avant parce que j'ai pu en
france par map organisons et quand même
aimé génie votre vie tout nous on s'en
remet aux programmes falvo la années des
programmes que je garde c'est un manque
de confiance confiance en vous saviez 12
ça vient pas nous fait reflet de la
programmation et cette programmation là
c'est ça qu'on dégage comme énergie en
avoir les autres donc quand on est dans
cette programmation de manque de
confiance en nous c'est 50 de gages et
ça ce qu'on reçoit
selon on n'est plus connecté avec nous
donc dégage non confiance ça revient mes
fesses je souhaite
ta rentrée mais qui connaît et dégager
cette énergie incroyable incroyable
qu'est ce qui se pose est ce que ça
tente de faire une petite expérience
avec moi ok dans chacun de nous comme un
être humain
ammann est dans notre vie ça on sentait
pas bien avec nous d'accord imagine
cette étoile dans battle jeu se
retourner dans cet endroit alors que
vous sentez pas gay ok tu non pas en
face à maintenant juste toucher la
personne à côté de vous avec votre main
par faits remontent au 19 partout
maintenant imaginez un couloir votre
couleur préférée bleu jean va n'importe
quelle couleur
je sais mais je n'ai que le vous êtes
dans cet endroit lors de fêtes couleur
vous rentrez chez vous tout
m'intéressait couleurs où vous êtes en
voyage et voyons si un peu et vous
imaginez dans votre tête vous savez ça
coule à dakar avec moi mais nachos la
même personne que vous avez touché quai
c'est quoi la différence entre les deux
touchés d'après vous quand vous touchez
la première fois votre cinquante à
soixante quinze mille pensées étaient là
au nom je peux pas toucher
je ne connais pas lieu ou non qu'est ce
qui se passe je la dette à temps pour
qu'ils me demandent de touché et quand
on fait le switch de rentrer dans la
couleur il fait la même expérience pour
penser et ebola waouh
vous n'avez pas d'idée préconçue vous
avez juste partager le moment avec
l'autre personne cessonnais dans notre
club à najib votre vie appartenait à
partir de ce moment à l'eau incroyable
on parlais tantôt au niveau de changer
infractions secondes pour lui faire
changer notre façon d'être programmé est
connecté avec nous
comment construire mais présent avec ou
eco et remet donc partage cette couleur
actuellement imagine comment que vous
dégagez cette information-là aux autres
maintenant j'ose est présent respirer et
jose toucher cette personne là dans
votre plan merci